GLAD YOU BROUGHT UP THE KIDS.
BEFORE THE BREAK WE TALKED ABOUT
HOW YOUNG KIDS ARE BEING RADICAL
IDES.
I WANT TO PLAY A VIDEO OF YOUNG
KIDS BEING RECRUITED BY ISIS.
[ KIDS CHANTING ]
>> SO WHY CHILDREN?
IS THIS JUST PROPAGANDA, OR ARE
CHILDREN THIS YOUNG FIGHTING?
I'LL ASK MIA FIRST.
>> SO DON, AS YOU KNOW, THIS IS
THE RESEARCH THAT I'M DOING NOW,
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WAYS NOT
JUST WHY CHILDREN ARE BEING
RECRUITED, BUT HOW TO PREVENT
IT.
ACCORDING TO THE ISIS SPOKESMAN,
CHILDREN UNDER 16 ARE NOT BEING
RECRUITED.
BUT WE HAVE SEEN CHILDREN AS
YOUNG AS 7 HOLDING UP SEVERED
HEADS.
WE HAVE SEEN CHILDREN IN SOME OF
THE VICE VIDEOS, THE VICE NEWS
VIDEOS ABOUT THE ISLAMIC
CALIPHATE SHOWING CHILDREN 9,
10, 11 YEARS OLD BEING TRAINED
ON AUTOMATIC WEAPONRY.
SO I DON'T THINK IT'S JUST ABOUT
THE PROPAGANDA.
IT'S CERTAINLY ABOUT PREPARING
THE NEXT GENERATION AND MAKING
AND INSURING THAT THESE CHILDREN
HOLD SOME OF THE SAME VALUES AND
IDEOLOGY.
IT'S A KIND OF BRAINWASHING, BUT
WE ARE ALSO SEEING CHILDREN AS
FRONT LINE FIGHTERS.
AND MY WORRY IS GOING INTO THE
FUTURE VERY YOUNG CHILDREN AS
SUICIDE BOMBERS.
>> QUICKLY, MUBIN, SHE CORRECT
WITH THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY MIA IS CORRECT.
AND I ALSO WANT TO ADD A THING
IN "THE NEW YORK TIMES," A PIECE
TODAY ABOUT USING CHILDREN AS
INFORMANTS FOR THE SO-CALLED
ISLAMIC STATE.